ROOTG T
E COORDINATING O
WITHDRAWAL TAYLK T W ONS CATOGET
COTHAT
, LY A  OUR RESOURCE TO
LP VACCINATE THE
MA
HISTORIC ANNOUNCEMENT REGARDING
AMERICA'S LEADERSHIPTH.A KNOWS
.
WED MORE PEOPLDIE E WOY 600,00 V
UNITED STATES THAN FWA W VED.
NOW THE TRAGED
WE ALSO KNH TO
RECOVERY.
THE UNITED SVACCINATIN%
WITH AAS
H ONA HERCULEAN EFFORT ON
THMANAGE ONE OF THES COMPLICATED
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES   TGENUIT
VACCINE.
IT TOOK E FULLAPACIT  COMPANIES
D LID OC
E LOWEST
NUMBER OF DAILY HS
Y OF THIOUR ECONG.
ALREADY SAVENDT GROWING EACHALL
LIVES. THE OIDENCYNS TO GET
THAT WE NEED TO CK T
LY AS
THIS IS ABOUT R
IO
SAVE AS MANY AS WE CAN
BITYO OUR
ALL PEOPLE IT DIGNITY
AMOUTO
HELP AND A HAND. WE ARNG
ANYWHERE AD THE E
SEEKO HELPS BEST
BOTH REPUBLICANRESIDENTS THE MN
KE CNG
THE GAINST HIVA.I.D.S., AND IN
D T
ERTHA RISK OF NEW ONS THAT COULO
RAISESTAS GOVERNNTD N
TOATES,  EVIDEE  DAY
GROWING S  PEOPLE.
OUR
HEMEOMY
BEGIN TOOVERWORST S IN A C. 2LI
DECLINE IN LONG-TEROYMENT, BUSA
ECONIC GROWTHE
FASTEST INEAY FOUR
A.
JUST AS NO'S,  IR  HE GLOBAL
OMY BEGIN TO RECOVER
APN
GET THIS PANDEMIC UNDENTDW WHY I
BEF VACCINESOUR FIT T
JUST AS AMERICA WAARSENAL
TOT.NTRIBUTED MORE THAN O KOVAC.
INDIOW. WITR ITH PARTNERSHIPS WP
NEIGHBORS, CANADA AND , THS AGOE
TESES OF OUR H VACCINES TY AMER
OWN VA HOUSE NOW TO THTHE WORLD
UNE.MANY OF THESSES ARIP
TO COUNTRIES AWORLD AS
WE SPEAKEP THAE GLOBAL FIGHT
THDEMIC.Y DIRECTUNITED AT WADDI.
PFIZ, THAT W
NEARLY 100OW
INCOME COUNTRIES, THEY W
THE BEARIES. THAAGN.
TATES WILL PURCHASE
A HALF A BILLION
NAAR INGAINST
THIS PANDEMIC.E SI
OCOVID-19 VACCIS Y SINGLE EVER.
IMPORTANTLY, THIS  M IS PROVEN I
COVID-19 AND EVERYWN
T TH.
THESE HALFILLL SHIPPED IN
AUGUST AS QUICKLY AS THEY ROLL
E MANUFACTURING .200 MILLION OF
BEELIVERED THIS  IANLLDELIVERED
.
LET ME BEAR.
STRINGS ATTACHED. HAILONOUSLY AO
OUR VACCINE DONATIONS DON'
POIACOSIWE'RE DOINTHIS
TOPANDEM IT.
PERIOD.
I ALSO
FOJO TAYTTEN TO KNOW EACH OTHER
STT THISRITICAGA LLY
PANDEMIC.
S FOLL
INCLUDING ATS  THE TO BE
DEFEAT ANT INRS, OMAT PLA IT ,L
GLOBHRCI I.
HAT BECAME KNOWN AS NAL OF DEMO.
EWN OF
AMERICAN MEN ANDENIN TTEILAR
N FEBR.RLD PEAC HD- WAS GRACIOUN
IE INGENUY,
TLE DOSE AS TOURE
MOST OF   TY
WORKER THERETH FEEL, IN Y'I'VE E
CAREER.
T CA
PROUD OF WHAT THEYE DOING.LY, TE
AMERICANL NOW
OF PEOPLA,SITHBBEAN.
HAET, PLACESY'VE SION AN T LIVEH
THANKS T
AMERICAN
AND ESSE WITH THISA MONUMENTAL S
SAF
PEOPLE WHO
WE'RE T, BUT WST
UP.
NOT ALONE
ENDEAVOR, THAT'S THE POINT I
WANT.
WE'RE GOING TO HELP LEAD THE
WORLD OUT OF THIS PANDIC,
INGS .
DETHHE
G-ELIVER
DINATEFORTS TOCC- TION IS THONL
VACCINATE THE WORLD.
THITE ER, HAS LED
CAMPAIGN TO GECCINATED ACROSS T
N GENEROUSATION.
TOMORROW, THE G-BENNOUNC OF
OUR ONSIBILITY,  THE MOMENNT TO
WE HAVE TO TURN G SFFORTS ONNA
DOSE SHOTST PEOPLE IN COUN THE T
CLNDING FROM  OF THE
AND WORKING THS  ASID
WE
MAFAG DOSES. DOSES
GETTJAAYINRM
VIRUS.THE WORLD HAS AT
I NT TTH TO  FCERMAN PFIR,T RSYU
FOR STPI
>> THANK YCH.PRESIDENT, AND
TOWIS OF COURSE A GREANO
TOGETHER FOR THIENT. C
SUMMIT THELD
LDE OF THUL
WHILE GREAT PROGRESS IN MANYEV
VACCICOUNTRIES.
MR. PREN KNOW FROM
FINANCIAL ITRACEON OR  DESERVE
FU ADMINISTRN FOYO
AD IN THIS
TOY  P
MIHE
BICH V TO TH
ESNATH WSIHAILITY TOR PRIDIOVAC
THANKS TO THE INIT
ENOFTILL NTIST T F SO WE SEEATHE
HAVE WORK TO I CAN
.SSUREOUESENTLESS INPURSUING MOD
AN CNUINEGNANT11 YEAR GLOBAL PH,
WE ARE ALSO CLOSELNITORING ESSI
VARI. OURCI O ANTS AND WE ARUTH
DAT VARIANT SS.
E DEUR VACCINE.
L, N
TO DEVEL WN 100 DAYS A
VA FORBID.
LSO PUUI
L
GS D APPL
B
MIORTANC AOUTODAY, MICEVYOS PRT.
NEHBS DOWN STREET,
U.S. GOVERNMENT GETSOANDCALY  E
HA OUR ABIO SAVE E LIVES ACROE.
ATIENCNSTTLE AIN
>> MR. PRESIDENT, DO Y
>> M PELVE MEETING WITH PUTIN C?
R.D